bonjour hélène laporte jours merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale verte et france
on vient d'entendre marine le pen qui
assume pleinement finalement cette
normalisation du parti est ce que tout
le monde est rentré dans le rang il n'y
a plus de dissensions de divergences sur
la stratégie à adopter
non alors des dissensions des
divergences objectivement j'en ai jamais
vraiment vu et on nous sommes rentrés
dans le rang nous sommes un parti comme
les autres
moi je me suis jamais sentie d'extrême
droite ou autre quand on est qualifiés
d'extrême droite c'est une erreur
profonde un nous sommes partis qui
aimons la france qui aimons la nation
qui aimons nos traditions qui est monde
si notre souveraineté et ça j'en pars en
tant que député européen et par rapport
à ça peut en continu nous sommes en
ordre de marche vers la présidentielle
oui elle le dit elle-même marine le pen
il n'y aura pas de retour en arrière
donc clairement la ligne s'est quelque
peu adouci la une ces quelques pages
aussi c'est à dire qu'en fait nous nous
sommes un parti de rassemblement on a pu
le voir puisqu'il ya diverses
personnalités politiques qui nous ont
rejoints de divers ports politique et
par rapport à ça on est dans une ligue
où seul parti qui ce qui est prêt à
gouverner
c'est pourquoi donc donc c'est une
normalisation justement en vue de se
présenter elle l'a dit marine le pen
pour pour la présidentielle ça a
commencé la campagne marine le pen en a
d'ailleurs profité pour attaquer le
le groupe l'est républicain écoutez là
avec xavier bertrand s'est voté pour moi
au premier tour voter pour macron au
deuxième ce fameux duel à marine le pen
emmanuel macron avec xavier bertrand
peut-être en troisième personnage pour
pour la présidentielle oui peut-être
xavier bertrand ou peut-être même
quelqu'un d'autre puisque au niveau des
républicains il ne peut pas dire qu'ils
se soient vraiment partie de cohérence
puisque il salit un petit peu avec tout
ce qui peut passer pour remporter l'an
l'avion au niveau des dernières
élections régionales ou des ralliements
qui se sont produits dans le cadre des
élections départementales
donc ça sera xavier bertrand ou un autre
mais nous en tout cas nous faisons tout
pour être en ordre de marche
votre second tour de la présidentielle
et surtout que marine le pen arrive à
l'elysée le président de debout la
france nicolas dupont aignan a tenu son
université d'été également ce week-end
en même temps que le congrès du
rassemblement national
à quoi joue nicolas dupont aignan selon
vous et il fait du pied à l' aile droite
des républicains alors que il avait été
pressenti pour être premier ministre si
marine le pen l'avait emporté en 2017 et
monsieur du poignon il fait du pied là
où il peut espérer continuer à rester en
vie entre guillemets puisque c'est un
parti qui est quelqu'un qui est pas dans
le déclin parce qu'il n'a jamais été
très haut non plus un au niveau des
sondages ou autre mais il a du mal quand
même à rester à rester de bourdon qui
s'essaye de s'allier avec les
républicains il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont partis chez dupont aignan pour
nous retrouver voyant vienne dupont
aignan des ans lisaient les gens qui
resté avec lui à ne jamais pouvoir
accéder aux responsabilités et de fait
bien il essaye de trouver une cohérence
ailleurs mais il a beaucoup de mal je
pense à nicolas dupont aignan qui s'est
érigé en tout cas on défenseurs des deux
seules et qui renaît go styrène est
traité européen à écouter si on veut
l'emploi si on veut re localiser il faut
retrouver notre liberté nationale
ça ne veut pas dire fréq site ça veut
dire renégocier je serai le candidat de
la renégociation des traités européens
est ce que cette renégociation des
traités cette scission
avec la politique actuelle de l'europe
le rassemblement national le porte
toujours à oui alors même je vais vous
dire c'est quelque chose que même quand
enfin en tant que député européen je
porte particulièrement je suis
coordinatrice au niveau de la commission
des budgets pour mon groupe identité
démocratie et je suis persuadé que le
fric si ce n'est pas la solution je suis
persuadé qu'en tant que second
contributeur net com et la france nous
pouvons avoir une position différente et
nous pouvons négocier tout un tas de
choses
nous nous sommes nous sommes la deuxième
puissance au niveau européenne
vous êtes des porcs avaient chacun vous
êtes d'accord mais finalement avec ce
que dit nicolas dupont aignan il faut
redonner gossier les traités européens
jeunes ont passé plutôt dessus du
poignet qui se rallie à nous parce que
marine le pen depuis le départ enfin
depuis plusieurs années dit bien que
nous sommes pour une europe des nations
et des coopérations ce qui ne veut pas
dire sortir de l'europe
la renégociation des traités c'est l'une
des premières choses que madame le pen
sera une fois qu'elle sera à l'elysée
avec notre notre position de second
contributeur net
on pourrait très bien voir une autre
position au niveau de l'union européenne
que celle que nous avons actuellement on
va parler de la crise sanitaire hélène
la porte à présent avec ce risque de
rupture entre les personnes vaccinées
les personnes non vaccinées c'est ce que
craint le gouvernement gabriela talent
le porte parole du gouvernement l'a
répété ce week-end regarder il faut
éviter une situation où l'épidémie
reprendrait notamment du fait de
personnes qui ne se sont pas fait
vacciner et imposerait de prendre des
mesures de restriction qui s'imposerait
à des personnes qui l ont fait l'effort
de se vacciner on voit les prémices de
ce ressentiment
il faut à tout prix rester unis est-ce
que ce risque de scission existe selon
vous oui il existe mais parce qu'aussi
le gouvernement le met en place moi je
regrette encore une fois une division au
niveau des français on va ostracisés
dans ce cas là dans les personnes
vaccinées des autres personnes des
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
toujours mettre les français dos-à-dos
que ce soit dans n'importe quel domaine
finalement parce que de ça revient trop
régulièrement
stigmatiser une population par rapport à
août est-ce qu'il faut vacciner est ce
qu'il faut une vaccination obligatoire
pour les soignants pour les salariés il
ya eu beaucoup d'appels ce week end en
ce sens et pour la population en général
alors moi j'estime qu'en temps politique
est alors en plus en tant que politique
qui parce que toutes les personnes qui
s'expriment à ce niveau là les
politiques ne sont pas tous médecins
loin de là moi je sors d'une carrière
juridique et j'étais dans une banque
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec les
médicale je trouve qu'on a on a déjà je
suis contre une vaccination obligatoire
mais en plus je pense que nous ne sommes
pas légitime pour nous pour imposer
aucun pour transmettre le message de
dire aux gens vaccinez vous ce n'est pas
notre rôle
si les personnes ne sont pas vaccinés
c'est parce qu'elles ont une défiance
s'il ya une défiance il faut l'entendre
et s'il faut l'entendre faut y apporter
une réponse et par rapport à cette
réponse c'est plutôt au laboratoire
c'est plutôt à des médecins c'est plutôt
à des infectiologues
si toi des virologues de devenir
l'expliqué sur plateau mais deux mais de
manière à ne pas mettre l'autre en
défaut tout peut s'entendre tout peut se
dire mais je pense que pour ça il faut
les bons interlocuteurs et ce n'est pas
spécialement politique de le faire
même certains membres du gouvernement se
sont à des médecins de faire ce sont à
des laboratoires les défiances qui a si
tout le monde ne se fait pas vacciner
c'est parce que on entend parler
d'effets secondaires
voilà c'est parce qu'il ya une certaine
crainte moi personnellement je suis pour
les vaccins les vaccins qui sont
obligatoires parce qu'il ya aussi un
recul par rapport à ça cette maladie
elle est loin d'être stabilisée en effet
le vaccin c'est certainement la solution
pour pouvoir l'éradiquer à terme mais il
faut qu'ils aient vraiment une grande
campagne de mobilisation mais deux
personnes qui sont audibles sur le sujet
et je ne pense pas que ce soit les
membres du gouvernement actuel qui le
font qu'ils soient les plus audibles
même sur l'exemple watts qui a eu
successifs mais laissez moi même pour
les soignants faut-il leur imposer la
vaccination selon vous non non non non
moi je suis vaccination obligatoire
marine le pen a été saisie par dont les
soignants il travaille au coeur du
métier ils sont au coeur de clini
d'hôpitaux de maisons de retraite
ce sont des personnes qui ont d une
culture médicale
donc s'ils ont des six ont des
restrictions par rapport à ça elles sont
fondées
donc par rapport à ces à cette mise à
l'écart qu'ils font il faut des
personnes audible en face d'eux pour
pouvoir leur expliquer pourquoi il faut
se vacciner et ce n'est pas je pense aux
politiques de le faire marine le pen
d'ailleurs a été vaccinée elle a reçu
ses deux doses on a appris également ce
week-end une quatrième vague est
peut-être en perspective dès juillet
c'est ce qu'a dit olivier verront
regardez nous devons aller encore plus
vite dans la vaccination
c'est une course contre la montre qui se
joue dans notre pays les vaccins font
chuter le risque de formes graves y
compris avec le variant delta depuis
cinq jours le virus ne baissent plus il
ré augmente à cause du variant delta qui
est très contagieux
l'exemple anglais montrent qu'une vague
est possible dès la fin juillet est ce
qu'on aurait pu éviter qu'une cnuced la
ga en juillet selon vous oui parce que
alors c'est vrai qu'au niveau du taux de
personnes qui sont vaccinées on est à 3
51% depuis hier les personnes qui ont
une dose et 36 % de la population qui
est totalement vacciner le problème ça a
été un point de communication dès le
départ au niveau du gouvernement
la défiance je ne sais pas si elles
étant dans le vaccin que tendance que le
gouvernement nous dit il ya eu quand
même le couac des masques de masques ne
servait à rien alors c'est pas une
question de revenir dessus mais c'est la
question de dire que tous ces couacs et
ben ils ont forcément un incident sur
les informations que nous recevons de la
part du gouvernement est ce qu'on peut
leur faire confiance
il est là le problème c'est pour ça que
moi je pense que pour qu'ils aient une
vaccination qui s'accélère il faut que
ce soit uniquement des personnes qui ont
un message audible
je vous dis les personnes qui sont un
petit peu réticente mais je pense que
des personnes travaillant dans les
laboratoires il faut qu'elle vienne
expliquer le vaccin en quoi il consiste
expliquer les effets secondaires
expliquer aussi le taux d'effets
secondaires par rapport à la population
vaccinée pour voir que c'est vraiment un
film explique également qu'il ya des
effets secondaires dans ton médicament
mais que tout se passe bien je
généralement ça c'est très important
cela ces messages il faut qu'il soit
transmis par des personnes audible et
les couacs successives du gouvernement
n'ont pas aidé à la confiance de la
population
on va parler à présent des manuels mâcon
qui pourrait annoncer cette semaine le
maintien des de la réforme des retraites
et le report de l'âge de la retraite à
64 ans voyez ce qu'on dit richard
ferrand le président de l'assemblée
nationale est plutôt méfiants ont
regardé la réforme des retraites ne
saurait être abandonnée enterré ce
projet comme se précipiter serait une
folie à mes yeux
réaffirmons clairement ce que nous
voulons faire engageons nous à ce que ce
soit notre première réforme du second
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron voilà le
repousser cette réforme aux au deuxième
mandat s'il y en a un pour emmanuel
macron est-ce que c'est prématuré de
remettre cette réforme des retraites sur
la table selon google elles n'apportent
c'est une question de calendrier
alors comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure je suis député européen et par
rapport au plan de relance et par
rapport aux fonds qui vont à décaisser à
partir de cet été
et bien en fait cette réforme des
retraites elle fait partie des
conditions d'obtention par rapport à ce
plan de relance alors bien évidemment
on va récupérer quelques milliards pour
rembourser beaucoup plus sain parce
qu'on n'ose met en avant les ressources
propres pour pouvoir rembourser ce plan
de relance ce qui ne se passera pas
puisque ça ne pourra pas fonctionner
mais c'est surtout que par rapport à ça
l'europe impose un certain nombre de rop
de réformes au niveau des états membres
pour avoir pour baisser en fait à leur
cou et cette réforme des retraites elle
arrive à ce moment là puisque c'est le
calendrier d'europe qu'il impose au
niveau de la france et c'est ce en quoi
moi je ne sais faire le ratio national
nous ne sommes pas pour le fric si nous
sommes pour une révolte de renégociation
et de notre position notre position en
tant que second contributeur devrait
être différente et on pourrait dire et
on pourra imposer le fait non en france
il y à des domaines dans lesquels
l'europe ne peut pas entrer notamment au
niveau social et cette réforme des
retraites nous ne la ferons pas parce
que nous allons faire des économies
ailleurs donc ce calendrier ne m'étonne
pas parce qu'il est complètement dicter
au niveau de l'union européenne
un mot sur cet homme qui a qui a menacé
d des personnes et des enfants dans une
gare du val d'oise il a été abattu par
deux agents de la sûreté ferroviaire
jean baptiste djebbari a pris position
pour une zone ont été mis en examen cdc
deux agents de la sûreté ferroviaire
écouter jean baptiste djebbari ministre
délégué aux transports
c'est un individu dont on a su a
posteriori qu'il avait un casier
judiciaire très fourni et qui s'est
montré très menaçant à l'égard de
passagers du groupe d'enfants à
plusieurs reprises y compris verbalement
je soutiens ces agents dont l'intention
a été de protéger des passagers et un
groupe d'enfants est ce que pour vous
voulez l'intervention de ces deux agents
étaient légitimes
complètement on ne rendrai tendres
étaient devant quoi si ça se trouve
devant des meurtres et autres là quand
je vois qu'ils sont mis en examen mais
dans n'importe quel autre pays aurait
reçu une médaille
ils ont protégé la population et c'est
un acte de bras
pour qu'ils ont eue et heureusement
qu'ils étaient là et merci et moi je
serai là la maman de ses enfants qui
étaient là mais mais mais cet homme je
le remercierais bien évidemment que
c'est triste quand on en arrive un grand
pareil mais mais mais ce n'est au départ
il ya quand même un homme qui menacent
des enfants donc moi cette mise en
examen alors certains il y avait bien
sûr il ya le droit il ya une juridiction
qui s'applique mais bon c'est c'est
toujours un peu incompréhensible et je
vous dis dans d'autres pays seraient
plutôt passé en en personne a vraiment
remercier au nom de la nation à la
télévision vous remercie beaucoup élèves
laporte d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct dans l'interview politique de
la matinale